can my boss force me to get vaccinated
who has the authority to enact vaccine
mandates who can ask about my
vaccination status these are some of the
questions society has been grappling
with as we've begun to open up after
months in relative lockdown amid a
global pandemic and in some places the
fights are heating up could mean police
officers and firefighters are not exempt
this testing will not be done on our own
time or our own dime if you want to go
out and have fun and go into a
restaurant or a bar you're going to have
to get vaccinated yeah it was a
no-brainer i'm still not taking it one
of the most public places these disputes
are playing out is in the federal
government president joe biden said he
won't mandate federal employees get
vaccinated but unvaccinated federal
employees will have to submit to
frequent testing and mask wearing this
approach is what's known as a soft
mandate a hard mandate is basically
vaccinate or you're fired if we're
talking about demand in the workplace a
soft mandate is amanda that says
vaccinate or do these other things
in the past hospitals for example said
vaccinate or mask you're not being fired
if you don't vaccinate but there may be
additional burden to reduce the risk you
pose to others
soft mandates like these are
increasingly being used by workplaces
even the nfl announced that players will
not be required to get vaccinated but
any game that's cancelled due to kovid
will count against the team responsible
for the outbreak forfeited games will
count against a forfeiting team's record
and players won't be paid for forfeited
games but when it comes to private
entities the law is increasingly coming
down on the side of those who wish to
impose mandates so if you've ever been
to a restaurant down the shore and it
says no shoes no shirt no service
uh vaccines can be thought of in the
same way no vaccination no service but
there's still some legal uncertainty
there the vaccines have been authorized
by the fda for emergency use
authorization which means they've gone
through rigorous testing however they
don't have full approval the reason for
the legal uncertainty is that the eua
law
tells the secretary of health and human
services to inform recipients that they
can accept or refuse the vaccine
some people say if people are told they
can accept or refuse the vaccine that
means no mandate on the other hand the
act also tells the secretary to inform
people of potential consequences so
there may be consequences to refusal
including maybe being fired and further
the act only talks to the secretary of
health and human services not to
employers not universities not to states
so
reading into that act a global
prohibition on employers and
universities and state to do something
they have long held the authority to do
is reading a lot into it now there are
two exceptions and that employers and
universities need to make note of so the
first is the americans with disabilities
act and so what that means is if someone
has a medical reason that they
can't get vaccinated there needs to be
accommodations for that and then the
second exception is for
religious objections so people who don't
get vaccinated for religious reasons you
also have to make accommodations for
them
a reasonable accommodation
there is no strict definition that
currently exists testing or masks can be
a reasonable accommodation you say we
will let you work just as everybody else
but you have to meet these additional
requirements to reduce the risk you have
tests twice a week you have to mask
another accommodation and it's really
going to depend on the workplace whether
this is possible is allowing employees
that do not want to vaccinate to
continue working remotely generally
reasonable accommodation is a
case-by-case question it depends what
the
workplace environment is what the job is
etc what would count as reasonable
i think that there's a lot of confusion
around this because there's this law
called hipaa that has to do with privacy
of your health care information but the
thing is is what hipaa says is that your
doctor or your health insurer can't
share information without your consent
it doesn't say that a restaurant can't
ask you personally and then you say yes
or no so restaurants and stores
definitely can ask about your
vaccination status it's just your doctor
your health insurer can't share it
without your permission
these disputes are already playing out
in the court in june more than 150
employees at a houston hospital system
who refused to get the kovid 19 vaccine
were fired or resigned after a judge
dismissed an employee lawsuit over the
vaccine requirement and in august a
judge ruled norwegian cruise lines can
require passengers to be vaccinated
after florida governor ron desantis put
a law in place banning all vaccine
passports in the state desantis also
signed a law in july banning school
districts from imposing mask mandates
for students in order some school
districts in the state are already
planning to defy
what has happened with the kobit 19
vaccine is states and particularly
republican state legislatures are
passing laws that are being signed by
governors that say
there can't be a vaccine passport there
you can't mandate 7 19 vaccination
for employment you
can't
um mandate covad 19 vaccination in order
for kids to go to school there's a great
resource called the national academy for
state health policy and they have been
tracking all of the different states
that are passing laws relating to covid
19 vaccination and so as of the
beginning of august there are seven
states that have passed laws
that say employers can't mandate covet
19 vaccines and again just to put this
in context all states right now require
certain vaccines in order for
kids to attend public schools and it's
with covet 19 that we're seeing these
laws that are specific that say you
can't mandate copit19 vaccination
the vaccine hasn't been authorized for
children under 12 yet but as of august 6
59 of people above 12 have been fully
vaccinated according to the new york
times and convincing people to
voluntarily get vaccinated could help
slow the spread of the virus making
mandates less necessary
so they can offer incentives they can
say
we'll give people who vaccinate money
some of them have done that will give
people a vaccinate paid leave
ranging from four hours to two days that
i've seen you can recommend the vaccines
to your employees you can provide
education and you can make access easy
by bringing vaccinations to the
workplace some people may have access
issues they don't have time to take time
off to go get vaccinated so bringing the
vaccines to the workplace can help them
what polls have found is that
people believe they're primary care
doctors and so there is a lot of
misinformation going around and it's
totally fine if people are confused if
they're worried about getting the
vaccine that is a natural reaction and
so what i would really encourage
is
talk to your doctor talk to your
pediatrician and they can
answer any questions that you have and i
would just stress that
yes the vaccines have this title
emergency use authorization and
thy an emergency can sound scary that
there isn't enough research but
really what all public health
professionals are stressing is the best
way to protect you to protect your
family protect your community is to get
vaccinated